בפרק הזה נספק את המסגרת
לחשיבה על סביבות מחשב
שאפשר ליישם אותה גם על הלפטופ שלך
וגם להרחיב אותה עד לסופרקומפיוטרים
בסוף הפרק הזה
תבין את המושג הבסיסי של משאבי מחשב
ואיך הם קשורים אחד לשני
אז מה הם משאבי מחשב? פשוט מאוד
הם הרכיבים שמרכיבים מערכת מחשב
יש לנו את ה-CPU או יחידת העיבוד המרכזית
שמבצעת את רוב ההוראות, יש לנו זיכרון
או RAM שמחזיק נתונים באופן זמני
והוראות תוכניות
ויש לנו GPU-ים או יחידות עיבוד גרפי
שמיועדות לרינדור גרפיקה
אבל אפשר להשתמש בהם גם למשימות מחשוב כלליות
שדורשות הרבה עיבוד מקביל
כמו סימולציות מדעיות, ניתוח נתונים או למידת מכונה
המשאבים האלה עובדים ביחד להרצת תוכניות
ולכל אחד יש יחידות מדידה משלו
למשל יחידות CPU נמדדות בליבות
ומהירות שעון, בעוד שזיכרון נמדד בבתים
בגיגה, מגה וטרה-בתים
לכל אחת מהבעיות שלנו
נצטרך סט של משאבים
כדי להריץ אותן
חשוב לקחת בחשבון את המשאבים הנדרשים להרצתן
ביעילות. המיקום שבו רכיבי התוכנית מורצים
ורוחב הפס של התשתית שמחברת ביניהם
משחקים תפקיד משמעותי
בקביעת הביצועים הכוללים
למשל, GPU עשוי להיות מהיר לחישוב חלקים ספציפיים
של התוכנית שלנו, אבל אם טעינת התוכנית לזיכרון ה-GPU
לוקחת יותר זמן ממה שחוסכים
יכול להיות שיהיה מהיר יותר להשתמש ב-CPU במקום. עכשיו
בוא נדבר על שינוי סקאלה של משאבים קלאסיים
יש לנו שתי גישות: סקאלה אנכית
וסקאלה אופקית. סקאלה אנכית כוללת הגדלה
של העוצמה של משאב יחיד
כמו שימוש ב-CPU חזק יותר או זיכרון גדול יותר
בתוך צומת פיזי אחד
כאשר צומת הוא יחידת אשכול מחשוב שמכילה מספר
משאבים. סקאלה אופקית
כוללת הוספת משאבים נוספים
כמו מספר CPU-ים או GPU-ים
שיעבדו יחד על צומת אחד או מספר צמתים
לשתי הגישות יש יתרונות משלהן
וחסרונות, והבחירה תלויה בצורך הספציפי
ובדרישות. בוא נציג סוג חדש של משאב
משאבים קוונטיים. משאבים קוונטיים מעבדים מידע קוונטי
עם יחידת עיבוד קוונטית או QPU. QPU
הוא המערכת השלמה האחראית
לקבלת סט הוראות קוונטיות להרצה
או circuit קוונטי ולהחזרת
תשובה מדויקת. זה אומר
שה-QPU כולל אחד או יותר שבבים קוונטיים
למשל שבב קוונטי של IBM
וגם רכיבים נוספים רבים
במקרר דילוציה
שמקרר את השבב הקוונטי
כמו מגברים קוונטיים, אלקטרוניקת שליטה
והמחשב הקלאסי הנדרש
למשימות כמו שמירת הוראות
וצורות גל בזיכרון, הצטברות תוצאות
ופענוח תיקון שגיאות עתידי
באופן כללי, משאבים קוונטיים נמדדים
מבחינת האיכות, סולם נאמנות שכבות
מספר ה-qubit-ים
והמהירות - פעולות שכבת circuit לשנייה
או CLOPS. היום נתייחס לשבב הקוונטי
כיחידת מדידה, בדומה לאיך שמערכות ניהול משאבים
מתייחסות ל-GPU-ים, לא לפי מספר הליבות
אלא לפי היחידה השלמה. מה לגבי סקאלה?
כמו משאבים קלאסיים, שינוי סקאלה של משאבים קוונטיים יכול
גם להיות מסווג לאנכי
ואופקי. סקאלה אנכית
תהיה הגדלת מספר ה-qubit-ים לכל chiplet
או לכל שבב
סקאלה אופקית תהיה חיבור שבבים
באמצעות couplers או חיבורים קלאסיים
עם ההגדרה הזו בצד
בוא נדבר על ניהול משאבים
ניהול משאבים בתשתית מחשוב מתייחס
לתהליך של תכנון
הקצאה ושליטה בשימוש במשאבי מחשוב
כמו CPU, זיכרון, אחסון
ורוחב פס רשת, כדי להבטיח
ניצול יעיל ואפקטיבי של המשאבים
אפשר לחשוב על ניהול משאבים
כמשחק טטריס רב-ממדי שבו הבלוקים
הם דרישות המשרה שלך
וכל ממד הוא יחידת משאב. המשימה הכללית
היא להכניס את בלוקי המשרה לתוך הקוביה של
כל המשאבים הזמינים שלך. ניהול משאבים
הוא משימה מאוד מסובכת ומתקני מחשוב שונים מיישמים
טקטיקות שונות להגדרת התשתית שלהם
לצרכים הספציפיים של בסיס המשתמשים שלהם
כדי ליישם את המושגים שלמדנו זה עתה, נשתמש
ב-Slurm. Slurm הוא תוכנת קוד פתוח
לניהול משאבים
למטרות הדגמה
יש לי הגדרה מקומית עם שלושה צמתים וירטואליים
אפשר לקבל מידע על מחשבי המחשוב האלה
על ידי הרצת פקודת scontrol
יש לנו שתי מחיצות או קבוצות צמתים
רגילה וקוונטית. המחיצה הרגילה מורכבת מצמתים
שיש להם גישה למשאבים קלאסיים בלבד
והמחיצה הקוונטית מאפשרת גישה למשאבים קוונטיים
בוא נריץ קודם את הדוגמה הפשוטה
"Hello World" הקלאסית עם Slurm
קודם כל נצטרך את תוכנית ה-Hello World עצמה.
וכאן התוכנית שלנו שפשוט מדפיסה Hello
World.
עכשיו צריך להגיד למנהל המשאבים
אילו משאבים אנחנו צריכים כדי להריץ את התוכנית הזו
כפי שדיברנו, Slurm מספק דרך לציין
את כל המטא-דאטה למשרה דרך
סקריפט shell
עם כמה אנוטציות ספציפיות ל-Slurm
האנוטציות האלה מאפשרות לך לציין דרישות משאבים
פרמטרי תזמון ועוד.
אפשר לבדוק את סקריפט ההגשה שלנו
וכאן יש ציון המחיצה
כמה צמתים אנחנו צריכים, כמה משימות לצומת שנריץ
כמה CPUs למשימה נשתמש
ואיזה סקריפט נרצה להריץ
וזו תוכנית ה-Hello World שלנו.
כדי להגיש את המשרה שלנו להרצה נצטרך רק להריץ
פקודה אחת שהיא sbatch
ולספק את הסקריפט שלנו כארגומנט
אפשר לבדוק את תור ההרצה
ולראות שתוכנית ה-Hello World שלנו רצה
על המחיצה הרגילה בצומת c1
כשהמשרה מסתיימת אפשר לבדוק את התוצאות
בהסתכלות על קובץ הפלט.
וזהו.
אנחנו גם מעוניינים להשתמש במשאבים קוונטיים
לכן בוא ניצור תוכנית Hello Qiskit פשוטה.
כאן תוכנית ה-Qiskit שלנו שכוללת את כל
השלבים הנדרשים של יצירת circuit
אופטימיזציה, הרצה ועיבוד לאחר מכן.
וכאן כל מושגי התכנות שדיברנו עליהם
circuit קוונטי, transpiler
ו-primitives של Qiskit
עכשיו צריך ליצור סקריפט הגשה
כמו קודם, אבל כאן נציין
דרישות משאבים קוונטיים
מכיוון שציינו את המשאבים
והמחיצה של האשכול
אילו משאבים קוונטיים זמינים
ה-primitives של Qiskit ישתמשו
במשאבים המוקצים לביצוע פעולות קוונטיות.
עכשיו צריך להריץ את התוכנית שלנו.
וכשהמשרה מסתיימת אפשר לבדוק את התוצאות.
וכאן ערך הציפייה שלנו.
וזהו לגבי ניהול משאבים
בחלק הבא נדבר
על מודלי תכנות